Alexis Moussine-Pouchkine: Hi, everyone.
We're here at Devoxx 2014, and
I'm here where Chet and Romain.
Chet, Romain.
Romain, Chet.
ROMAIN GUY: It's all the same.
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah.
It's all the same.
You don't even know who's who.
We're here to talk
about Android 5.
That you know what it is?
CHET HAASE: Yes.
Yes.
NICK BUTCHER: L stands for?
CHET HAASE: Lollipop.
NICK BUTCHER: Lollipop.
Awesome.
And people are
actually, as we speak,
getting their
updates over there.
So what are they
actually getting?
I hear things like material
design, material design,
and material design.
CHET HAASE: That's
pretty much it.
Those are the first
three elements,
and then there's a couple
after that, including material
design, and then also
the implementation
of material design.
ROMAIN GUY: There are
a few more features.
CHET HAASE: Are there?
ROMAIN GUY: Yeah.
CHET HAASE: OK.
That's certainly the ones
that I worried about.
So basically everything
that the team that I'm on,
which is the UI Toolkit Team,
worked on for the release
was all about material design.
Because the UX Team's
vision for material design
was so grandiose and
large, basically we
needed to work the
entire [INAUDIBLE]
to figure out how to
implement that thing.
NICK BUTCHER: So you
worked really hard
so developers don't have to?
CHET HAASE: That's
another way of putting it.
Sure.
NICK BUTCHER: So what are
developers getting, really,
with material design?
So there are things
like coloring,
there are things like,
obviously, animations,
and all of that is baked in
the platform at this point.
CHET HAASE: Right.
Right.
So I think one of the
things to come out of this,
like, if you go to these
talks and you sort of read
the articles, you're
like, well, so what's
this huge new swath
of APIs that I
need to use to implement
material design in my app?
And the answer is
actually not that much.
A lot of it just comes for free.
So when you opt into
the material theme
or if you're using
the support library,
you opt into the
AppCompat theme,
and then you're running
on the Lollipop release,
you're just going to
get a bunch of stuff
for free, which is the
colorizing of the assets.
So you're going to look
like the standard, which
it should look on the platform.
You're going to get
animations in a lot of areas,
icon animations.
You're going to get shadows and
elevation on standard widgets.
So all of that
stuff is for free.
Then you can choose to opt
into more material design
capabilities, like custom
animations or activity
transitions if you want to.
But you don't have to
do all of that stuff.
It's sort of a sliding scale
of how far do you want to go.
NICK BUTCHER: OK.
So that's obviously a big
piece, material design.
And users will see it.
Developers need
to understand what
it is that people will
certainly expect to see, too.
ROMAIN GUY: Developers
should definitely
go read the guidelines,
because there's
a lot to learn about
what's expected
in terms of animation--
NICK BUTCHER: So that
was a conversation
we had previously was is this
something for just designers
or should developers
really read this?
ROMAIN GUY: Well, yeah.
It's for developers,
but designers
should understand it as well.
NICK BUTCHER: And vocabulary
is probably something important
so everybody's on the
same page for that.
Beyond material design, there
must be a few other things.
So Notifications is one of the
first things that users see.
How does that surface in
the API to developers?
ROMAIN GUY: Well,
there's the new future
of adding the Notifications
on the Lock screen
so the users can
choose what they
want to expose on
their Lock screen,
because there's obviously
a privacy concern.
So applications
can tell the system
if the Notifications should
be Public, Private, or Secret.
And then the user
can decide if they
want to make private
notifications public
or if they want to keep
everything private.
So there's a lot around that.
CHET HAASE: There's new APIs
around colorizing your assets.
So further branding
of your application
by coloring your
Notification icons.
Sort of minor tweaks on top
of what Notification's already
doing.
NICK BUTCHER: Right.
But for the most
part, we're sticking.
And any use of the
existing Notification API
will just transfer?
CHET HAASE: That just works.
ROMAIN GUY: Yeah.
Everything that used
to work still works.
It looks better.
NICK BUTCHER: It looks better.
That sounds pretty good.
Concurrent documents.
So one of the things
people will see
is that when they look at
all their applications,
every Chrome page is rendered
as a separate document.
So is that something that's
available to developers
as well?
ROMAIN GUY: Yeah.
There's a new API.
Applications can decide
what is a document.
And they have a lot
of control over when
do they start a new
document, how many documents
do they want to
keep in that list.
And for certain applications,
like Docs or Chrome,
it makes a lot of sense.
It's not going to make as
much sense for other things,
like a media player,
a music player,
but it's up to the developers.
NICK BUTCHER: So one
thing I saw in the release
notes is the ability to have now
a Chromium-based WebView, which
was one of the new
things in KitKat.
To have some sort
of a modern WebView
with a number of new features.
It is now being unbundled in
the sense that it's there,
but it's being updated
outside of the main releases.
CHET HAASE: Yeah,
from the Play Store.
NICK BUTCHER: From the
Play Store directly.
CHET HAASE: Right.
So now the WebView
has the ability
to be updated from
the Play Store
so you can actually get more
recent updates to WebView
outside of the standard platform
releases at whatever time
schedule they're at.
NICK BUTCHER: Which
means whenever Chromium
has this new release with
support for, I don't know,
WebGL or what have you, you
can get it fairly quickly?
ROMAIN GUY: Well, and
more importantly for bug
fixes for instance.
NICK BUTCHER: Oh,
and that, of course.
CHET HAASE: Right.
Yeah, I don't know what the
specific plans are, like,
how frequently they
would release it.
The announcement was more around
the plumbing and the capability
to actually do the
unbundled releases
through the Play Store for now.
NICK BUTCHER: Great.
So any other APIs?
I'll get to runtime
implementation.
ROMAIN GUY: Many APIs.
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah.
I heard 5,000.
It scared be a little
bit, but we certainly
don't have time to cover
the 4,900 other ones.
Any ones that you want to cover?
ROMAIN GUY: Let's see.
I mean, I can talk about
APIs that I like personally.
The ability to run your
PS1, since I think it
can be very useful to
a lot of applications.
Obviously not all of them.
I also like the unification
of all the media session
APIs to be able to
control music playback.
Now there's a unified way
of creating a playback
UI in Notifications, because
now every media player
has its own way of doing it.
It can be a little
confusing for the users,
but now there's a common style.
And since applications can
brand their notifications,
it will still look like
your media application.
It's just easier for everybody.
NICK BUTCHER: So something else
you're probably interested in
is updates to OpenGL support?
So what's new there?
Is that just a
new rev of OpenGL?
ROMAIN GUY: Android 5 is
getting OpenGL 3.1, which
brings a lot of very
interesting features
to graphics programmers
and game developers.
And also there's
the introduction
of something called the
Android Extension Pack.
So it basically gathers
20 existing OpenGL Engine
extensions and packages
as a single one
so developers are guaranteed
that all of these extensions
will exist on all
Android 5 devices.
It's easier to
manage them that way.
NICK BUTCHER: So all
of that, by the way,
is now powered by a new runtime.
So ART is now the
new and only runtime,
and so there's no going
back to Dalvik, right?
ROMAIN GUY: There's
no going back.
CHET HAASE: Over
their dead body,
I think they would probably say.
Yeah, so ART is
a better runtime,
and it's the only one there.
It allows ahead of
time compilation.
It allows better, much faster,
and smaller pause time GC.
So allocation of objects as
well with collection objects
is much faster.
It also has the ability
to defragment the heap
by actually being
a moving collector.
So when your activity
goes in the background,
then that might be
an appropriate time
for it to actually gather
the objects together,
sort of to create larger spaces
in the heap, which was not
possible under Dalvik before.
NICK BUTCHER: So does that
actually help you reach, like,
those 60 frames
per second at all?
Was that a big--
CHET HAASE: Yeah.
Yeah.
Because the more garbage you
allocate, the more objects
you allocate.
Over time then, the garbage
collectors are going to come in
and say, well, I
need more memory.
I can't find memory
immediately so I'm
going to have to collect dead
references to actually create
the room to allocate
more objects.
And that took more
and more time.
The more fragmented
your heap would get,
the messier things got.
So then you'd see pause times.
If you'd just run
logcat, then you
would see pause times of
easily 10 to 20 milliseconds
when it would do a
full stop-the-world GC.
And now those pause
times are down
to, like, two or
three milliseconds
at a time, which
means it brings it
below that magical barrier
of 16 milliseconds.
16 milliseconds is
the amount of time
that you have to
do everything to do
to put the pixels
onto the screen
in order to maintain
60 frames a second,
say for animations or
other rendering stuff.
So if we can get the pause time
down to such a point where it's
less significant or not
huger than a single frame
just in and of
itself, then we've
got a much better chance of
maintaining a smooth frame
rate.
NICK BUTCHER: So if
people are interested
in the actual
implementations of the GC,
I would recommend they watch
the Google I/O sessions
that go into very much detail--
CHET HAASE: As well as the
Android Developers Backstage
Podcast.
We had a two-parter, because
I was so into the runtime
that we talked to
Anwar for much longer
than we were supposed to.
NICK BUTCHER: I listened
to both parts, actually.
CHET HAASE: OK.
NICK BUTCHER: So it
was interesting enough
for me to go until the
end of the second part
so I do encourage people to
listen to that one as well.
So let's see, Project
Volta battery usage.
Is that just an internal thing.
So we gather statistics
and we learn from it
then you guys can do stuff?
Or is it something exposed
to developers as well?
ROMAIN GUY: Well, it's
similar to what we did before
with Project Butter and
Project Svelte, which
was an internal project
gathering a lot of statistics
to understand what was
going on in the system,
obviously fixing the problems
as they were identified,
and then making available
the tools that were built
for internal use
to all developers.
So there is something called
the Battery Historian,
it's on github.com/google, and
it's the tool that was used
by the Android Team to
find all those issues.
CHET HAASE: It's actually
similar to a lot of the tools
that we've seen on Android.
Some of them look, you
know, a bit homegrown,
and it's because
they were, right?
So the GPU profiler
stuff, especially the
on device tools as well
as some of the DDMS tools,
you actually wrote
because you needed them
to [INAUDIBLE] the platform
in one way or another.
Like, I personally would
benefit from having
a tool that showed
me this information.
So you write the
tool, and then there's
no reason not to push the tool
out there for other people
to benefit from as well.
NICK BUTCHER: OK.
Anything else you want
to mention on maybe,
I don't know, your
favorite feature?
I know it's like choosing--
ROMAIN GUY: I mean, Android
5 is a huge release,
and I think everybody should
just go take a look at it.
There's [INAUDIBLE], you
can run the emulator,
the system images from each
of the devices are available,
look at the release notes.
I mean, there's
something for everybody.
NICK BUTCHER: Right.
And we didn't talk
about the devices,
but there is certainly some
new shiny devices to look at.
A phone, a tablet,
and certainly that
is a good way to first
experience as a user,
and probably as a
developer they're
really cool and
powerful devices.
Anything else?
CHET HAASE: Animations.
Lots of new animations.
That's always a
good thing, right?
ROMAIN GUY: That's
all you care about.
CHET HAASE: Yeah.
Well, it's-- sure.
Yeah.
OK.
NICK BUTCHER: Great.
Well, I guess that's all
the time we have for it.
Thanks, guys.
ROMAIN GUY: Thanks.
CHET HAASE: Thanks.
NICK BUTCHER: See you soon.
Bye, everyone.